it is a good day here it is December
here it is Monday morning it is the year
2018 coming to a close you know you can
hear mother nature and father time and
and the Lord you know you can hear
Buddha and all of them the whole crew
there they're boxing up the year they've
been using the year playing at all you
know like a board game and now they're
putting it back in the box things have
happened and people have come and go and
babies have you know crawled out of
crotches and and senior citizens have
have have crawled back into the earth
and that bad motorcycle of living and
life and dying and condensation and acid
rain and telecommunications and all of
it the whole whirlpool of existence has
almost come to the end of its coil for
this year 2018 and as the year goes into
the box all that's left to do is wrap it
up and put a bow on it and that's what
we're trying to do I think is just you
know if it's been good if it's been bad
if it's been ugly if you've lost someone
if you've loved someone it just
finish strong here and just put a bow on
it look forward to this to this new
beginning it's coming I'm happy to be
here with you guys welcome to this past
weekend
[Music]
Hey
[Music]
hmm I started to get a little bit lost
on what ah where we were in the song
that's jingle bells jingle bells and
some people say jangle jangle bells
some people say probably even jungle
bells probably you know knows people as
be honest they're they're probably not
doing super great people that say jungle
bells but thats jingle bells that was
sent in by a man named tiny sand who and
some people don't know who he is and
some people know who he is in tiny sand
who he's we've never seen him you know
and this was a this was a I guess he's a
man he said he was in emails he started
just emailing in riffs that he made with
his own fingers you know in his own ten
fingers I'm assuming he have he did he
have ten fingers and he made those riffs
for us and that one right there is
jingle bells and he sent that in to us
last year around this time of year and
so uh I just wanted to play it again so
that we could have that and just to
remind us how I remind me that so many
people have contributed to this bad
motor scooter right here of this past
weekend and thank you guys for being
with me today's episode is brought to
you by gray block pizza you know there
comes a time in every man's life when he
doesn't know what to do
and he doesn't know what direction to
take and if he if you find yourself
caught in the bosom of uncertainty you
can always go to grey block pizza 18:11
Pico Boulevard on the way to the beach
gray block get that hitter today's
episode is brought to you by minimal
case m in ml case it is the world's
thinnest iphone case now I'm talking so
thin
a baby could you know burped a baby who
had a heavy arm could just probably
break you know not break through it but
you know could well actually probably
couldn't do anything to it because it is
actually a case but but it is the
world's thinnest phone case and you can
have it it is just 0.01 inches thick it
is basically just a fine plastic sheath
for your phone and it covers the new
iphone excesses the XRS and pixel threes
those are all in stock showcase the
beauty of your phone bulky cases are out
of style says minimal case and there's a
hundred percent money-back guarantee if
you are unhappy for whatever reason they
will refund the purchase of the case no
need to even send the case back you can
get 20% off by visiting em in ml case CA
se calm and use promo code theo for 20%
off @m in ml case calm that's minimal
case and those things are thin it
basically like it's like putting a
condom like a hard condom on your phone
and you know that week Santa's coming
Santa dude in these days I think Santa
could probably catch some charges you
know it's a different time now a big
white dude rolls down a chimney
somewhere bro you know it's not gonna
work super well right now you know
probably a llama suprise a lot of you
know extreme liberal people they're
probably gonna put little caps on their
chimneys saying that you know they don't
they don't want to be a part of it I
heard somebody the other day a parent
out here in Los Angeles saying that they
didn't want their children celebrating
Christmas that it feels it feels errant
that gifts just come out of nowhere and
it creates an environment where they
feel like their children didn't do
anything but
getting gifts it creates a bad example
for their kids man [ __ ] that this is
Christmas man it's the one time of year
when you know old guy can wander around
and do something nice for a kid every
other old guy if it ain't your
grandfather it's a PDF file you know
with some guy who you know we can
cookies all day in and trying to touch a
little bit of young skin and that's the
thing I think on a lot of these you know
on senior citizens because a senior
citizen is just a regular person that
you know is just really you know that
the death is kind of starting to [ __ ]
flirt with that's all they are a senior
citizen is just a kid that's at like 70
or 80 years old you know I'm saying it's
just something really you know a senior
senior citizens really they're basically
just they're people that are starting to
bother everybody you know they're wild
and so some of them they just they lash
out if you've been ever been to a senior
care facility when I was in when I was
in high school went and lived with a
family and and and the mother was a
speech pathologist and she's to put
these suckers these little lollipops in
like a senior citizens mouth and it the
lollipops had a little electric motor
hooked on to it on the stick of the
lollipop that you would put the stick
into this little motorized button thing
he pressed the button and the lollies
would would that lollies would spin in
the seniors mouth and it would get him
to start you know getting moist or you
know get him glistening and stuff on
that [ __ ] tongue and then they would
be able to talk easier and you know cuz
some of them had head strokes and you
know two strokes and [ __ ] you know
greens and regulation and bugging you
know birdies and double birdies they had
all kind of mental
their shoes and everything and they
couldn't barely sometime of their mouth
or talk and she put this little lolly on
their tongue and get that [ __ ] spinning
you know and then it would get on the
soft you know it would get them softened
up in the jowls and they could
participate and start to learn to
communicate rehabilitation that's what
they call they call that rehabilitation
in and so sometimes we get hi after
school and go in there and and she'd let
us go warm up one of the seniors because
she would do to lolly in their mouth for
a while and then have them do the
alphabet or you know you know they would
say like Wilma washes you know the
window sills or things like that little
tongue Tanglers you know Larry loves you
know liquid lozenges and say it as much
as you can and things like that every
brown car does fine things like that you
know what I'm saying you know Shane
Shane what does his Shane sell salmon at
make nut Macy's I don't know what it was
Shane she sells seashells salmon at the
seashore things like that different you
know you know little verbal you know
jump abouts they get your face happening
and so anyway sometime we get in there
Brian we get stone we come from school
and [ __ ] joint out and get all
[ __ ] pop-pop you know we'd have to
you know we'd have the devil [ __ ]
dancing behind you know you know dancing
behind our eyeballs and we get in there
and get a couple of those little
motorized lollies and [ __ ] just plop
them on a tongue of any senior because
they like that activity dude you put a
motorized lolly on us tongue of a senior
citizen bra
their holes body will start to sweat
some of them it's - it is a real because
for some of them that's the most it's
the most sexual action they've had in
decades maybe in semen sometimes we know
one time we got in there and my friend
beau he'd never been in there he'd never
been into the Senior Center and dude I
was in I was [ __ ] running around
hiding
you know I'd hijack a couple dollars and
[ __ ] like that a lot of them had stamp
collections and [ __ ] or not get in there
and you know look at the stamps and be
all high and just you know put on
they're different sometimes they had you
know big jackets and big sweaters and I
put on some of their clothes and just
you know [ __ ] around at the scene you
know at the Senior Center and heat my
buddy beau one time he got in the I
didn't tell him that uh that III told
him that you got to go hug them all when
you see him right when when you see the
same seniors one of the rules you got to
go hug him and so next thing you know
he's hug he's just going senior of
senior you know giving him that [ __ ]
double arm you you know just that double
arm [ __ ] rum shackle just hitting him
straight up just chest to chest and uh
and some of the older ones would [ __ ]
you know grab his fat or do you know
touches even he was a little he had a
little bit extra weight on him at the
time and he had [ __ ] him you know uh
kind of kid tits on him you know
middle-aged kid he was like a
middle-aged child you know we're 15 I
guess and he kind of had a little bit of
tits on him and some of these seniors
you brah
they [ __ ] grab a boy's tit man cuz at
it's a ten you know people don't think
about that people think oh man I saw
these tits on this girl or whatever but
at it is a tent up teddy don't know if
it's on a man or woman a titty is just
doing its thing but yeah sometimes
seniors they'll touch a [ __ ] skin or
they'll do their naughty
I mean seniors or they're just children
hiding in very old skin and eyes and
hair that's all they are they're
basically just a kid like in a sleeping
bag but the sleeping bag is made out of
old skin and
and different stuff like that and you
know and sometimes they put baby powder
on and now with one of them they had
this one dude mister I guess I want to
say his name is mr. Damian this big
black guy bro and dude he put so much
baby powder on [ __ ] now
he thought he was [ __ ] four months
old bruh and sometimes you're talking to
him and he smells so much like baby
powder you would forget he was a senior
citizen especially when you're high dude
I'm sitting there high and mr. Damian
dude he was you know and he was urban
you know what I'm saying he was he was I
don't if he was a hundred percent
african-american but he was at least
maybe eighty or eighty eight percent and
he um but he wore so much baby powder I
mean he looked like damn Pablo you know
Juan Pablo Montana I mean he had just it
looked like he was just selling coke off
his shoulders he had so much baby powder
on him and you talk to him when you were
Stoney dude sometimes I thought he was
just a [ __ ] you know like a hundred
and sixty pound you know uh black infant
that was just really chatty did I get
way high we used to get way high on that
[ __ ] ditch smoke bro when people used
to grow eating ditches right out in
front of their homes so but anyway but
yeah you got to be careful my senior
citizens are very unique and rare
creatures and people forget about that
what happened this past weekend man oh
dude I'll tell you this
the
I went to dinner with David Spade's I
went to dinner with David Spade's
yesterday night and we've been
communicating some and it's kind of
crazy because people always talk about
Joe Dirt and this and that and then I
feel it's almost like enough people
talked about it and next thing you know
we're going to dinners and new when
you're going I didn't know what to wear
I mean I dude I was trying on all of
this [ __ ] I have which ain't much I got
a new Curious George sweater and um I
had a [ __ ] trench coat but part of it
was in a little bit of a fire and has
like uh I guess it looks more like a
wild western apocalypse kind of you know
like something maybe Ralph Lauren not
right maybe like a Ralph's yeah
maybe like Ralph Lauren and Australia
would sell it it's like a trench coat
but kind of has an apocalyptic type of
you know vibe to it but anyway so I went
to dinner with David Spade's and and it
was fun dude well he was talking to
stories about Chris Farley and uh and it
was just kind of fascinating and I
thought I was gonna be real real nervous
you know I thought I was gonna be real
nervous cuz it's David Spade's dude from
um who was in 50 first dates you know
he's Joe Dirt he's I mean uh you know
he's like an American Idol he's like
damn you know he's like kind of like a
he's like Willie Nelson but maybe like
more of like but that could work at a
library you know what I'm saying he had
the wild vibe but it was fun man it was
just fun to talk about different stuff
and I was telling stories about growing
up and yeah it was like a fancy
restaurant and there was like people
drinking you know [ __ ] oh that you
know you could hire like a poor person
to come over and just cry in your mouth
and it was like you know just it was
that expected was fancy you get anything
you wanted you could get you know
probably piss from
Neptune if you wanted a couple quarts of
that whatever you wanted they had it you
could have somebody come over and drink
their blood right out and out of her
neck you know a healthy person maybe
from Denver or from one of those
CrossFit groups it's that kind of place
I mean it's Los Angeles you can get
whatever you want unless you're a kid
here you can barely get Christmas
anymore
they said it's scary the lady said the
other day it's scary to have them too
for your children will imagine a man
they don't know coming down the tree
[ __ ] that ain't a man the Santa have we
lost it that is sing it tub it's Santa
it's not [ __ ] you know Jerry Lawler
it's not I don't know anybody else but
it you know these are seasoned
professionals for holidays you know next
it's gonna be like oh the Easter Bunny I
don't you know that it doesn't sound
safe to have a rabbit coming and
bringing you know unboiled eggs and
hiding them this sounds like a
Salmonella issue suck a dick this [ __ ]
man merry Christmas to everybody out
there he's celebrating that's what I'm
telling you but it was wild man I got to
be you know it was just kind of a crazy
thing dude and I didn't feel super
nervous I remember when I first met
David Spade's it was a couple years ago
and I was like okay I was standing talk
to him I was like all right am I do I
look crazy right now
do I seem does my do my arms do I have
both my arms on my body
you know is you know what's going on you
know how do I stand do I stand with one
shoulder pointing at him do I stand
just stand as tall as I can what do I do
when do I talk but it was just
comfortable to just be relaxed and we
had some tuna they had cuts a tuna god
no
this tuna [ __ ] so good it could have
been damn I don't know what it could I
mean it could it looked like a just I
mean like just like they just just the
Lord Himself they cut the backstrap
right out of dang Gia's Christ and just
sous-vide it or whatever sauteed it this
meat dude
brought you it was so [ __ ] you brought
it up to your mouth this tune of me you
brought it up to your mouth and it just
disappeared brother that's how good it
was it disciplined the minerals and the
vitamins risk in your body suddenly it
was that kind of thing
and David Spade's he's notorious around
Los Angeles for you know meeting a lot
of ladies and he's kind of like a sea
horse of a man he's like a little you
know he's kind of that cute little
delicate little magical creature but
also gots that horse you know somebody I
read somewhere I think in a chatroom or
like in the dark Internet that somebody
said the little guys got like a damn you
know probably six and a quarter inches
of [ __ ] on him and that's about a fifth
of his height probably I don't know tall
he is but and I don't know that good at
math but but dude it was just crazy to
be over there with david spade's and
just sitting there having dinner and
talking and just have just fun and I did
a couple comedy shows
so thank anybody that came out we threw
a gal out at the Comedy Store and I
guess I felt kind of bad about it but
she had this had her feet on the stage
and she was making she was just being
really selfish so that happened what
else happened lost my fantasy league
dude and I sent that gay text that you
send sometimes you're like oh well I
just want to say guys it was a good year
I had fun I [ __ ] hate heaven I wish I
wouldn't have sent it I had a great time
thank [ __ ] that I wanted to win you
worked so you know a lot of ladies out
there I don't think they realize how
hard men and work at fantasy football
it's the last thing we have is fantasy
football and the rules keep changing I
mean in another year or two the men
aren't gonna be allowed on the field
that's how crazy the rules are getting
you know it's just basically in a be
it's gonna be like people just two
different teams from different cities
playing pokemon cards what else oh I'll
realize this so oh I'll say this man I
don't want to tell you guys I'm afraid
that I'll start back but I'm this is my
sixth day and no smoking and I feel I
feel hopeful that's what I feel like you
know I just needed a change for myself I
needed something to adjust I hate smoke
and I like it but I I don't like the way
it makes me feel and in the end I'm
starting to think I just don't like
feeling no matter what I do I'm hard on
myself about it you know no matter what
I do if I do anything no matter what it
is it's like man you shouldn't be doing
that man you did that man it's like my
brain always says something it won't let
me enjoy anything really everything I do
there's something that's not right about
it so that's kind of what I've started
just realized recently and that's you
know I don't like that but you know I
can figure that out I'll start to figure
it out him but I don't like that it
makes it's like my brain doesn't want me
to enjoy my experience in the world
sometimes you know it's like oh I'll go
work out in Opera and I'll have a you
know food after I'm breathing like oh
you should have had different food than
that you had that [ __ ] or you know
I'll try you know I'll have a little
cuts of um you know London brawl at the
house you know because I used to have a
ton of London brawl and then I I started
thinking my brains like damn dude you're
gonna turn into like a damn British
person you know you have because one one
week I had about honestly
probably five pounds of London broil I
know it is a lot I guess but so my brain
just you know wants me to not have fun
sometimes so I have to just be aware and
know that guess what sometime I do want
to have fun no matter what I'm doing
some time I just want to be like well I
did it that's just something I did I'm
not a bad person I'm okay it's be gonna
be people being okay Pete Davidson makes
troubling Instagram posts man he's been
he's had a wild time huh
you know Pizza when you the times I've
been around Pete I'll say this he's all
he's always been extremely nice very
kind he is a very loving you know he's
almost like you think of a teddy bear is
like kind of a slough II you know a
fluffy little you know thing maybe who
got you know fluff in him and you know
little Cotton's and Pat you know little
packets of softener but and he's like
that but he's like a tall skinny one but
yeah just it just seemed like a lot of
pressure for somebody that's having some
mental who's who's mentioned having
mental health issues bipolar issues and
a scary I bet you know I'm never haven't
had anything like that but I can imagine
it scary and then he's in a big
relationship and the media doesn't care
those people don't care the news they
don't respect they don't give off huh
Hollywood doesn't give a [ __ ] they put
him on SNL an hour after he made a post
that said you know if he wanted to be
alive is that well I guess you know
don't change his eye maybe it's a bit
best way to do it just cruise along with
what he wants to do but Jesus who's
close to him and he just seems like he's
in a tough spot and I you know I can
understand it I know what it's like to
feel like you're in a tough spot and not
feel sure about yourself and so I'll
just hope he gets the help that he needs
if he if he needs help you know hope
that he gets the help that he needs
do
Joe Rogan tweeted that he would
interview Kanye and man I would love to
see that I would love to see that I hope
Joe Rogan ends up running the whole
world he secretly does it's just you
know people are slowly getting on to it
I think what do I know though um what
else
oh dude I've been realizing this so even
though I quit smoking my um you know my
jerking off has been kind of flaring up
at night not at the daytime I noticed my
my heavy desires to really touch out and
spray out of my own body
occur around 1:00 a.m. 12:40 1242 1:20 I
almost want to lock my dick away in a
special box because I'll find it and I
will find ways to you know but yeah I'll
just keep finding ways to touch my own
body until seed flies out of it you know
and it's kind of um it's tough it's
tough when you just do it you know when
you do it too much but but we'll see
we'll see man I'm not gonna feel bad
about it I just wish that I had a bit
more control over it
I mean I almost want to handcuff myself
to the [ __ ] neighbor's door or
something but the crazy thing is I've
been noticing when I do masturbation in
my room the neighbor's dog will start
barking and I don't know if anybody else
is a pet owner I've never been a pet
owner you know I got attacked by a bunch
animals when I was young two birthdays I
got attacked once cats and I also buy
dogs on a different birthday kind of a
group attack they did but yeah that kind
of stuff if you think that it's not you
know it's mmm it's just kind of alarming
to think that the dog knows I'm doing it
so if anybody has experience with that
where animals behave certain ways around
them while they're experienced and you
know full sexual or self sexual let
no let me know hit the hot line with
that nine eight five six six four nine
five zero three because I swear to God
that thing and it used to be that I had
a neighbor my neighbors had a cat and if
I would pleasure myself when I would
leave the apartment later the cat would
be out there in front of their apartment
and so something's going on I'm like the
damn you know beat master you know like
the Beast Master he had all these little
ferrets and little you know Guatemalan
[ __ ] steampunks under his arms and
[ __ ]
why make the beat Master do not jerk off
and all animals show up
that's like damn what's going on cuz
this is I mean I don't I don't think I'm
living in like a magical apartment
complex but if I'm doing masturbation
I'm doing self Skeet
you know I'm doing that [ __ ] you know
making my little own like you know my
own doing my own Old Faithful over at
the house then there must be something
going on you know I don't know if my if
my what's expelling out of my body is
coming out at a certain you know audible
octave or something if you know the
animals can hear it or if it's I don't
know if I've been eating something that
makes the scent of it real strong or
real primal but you know to that but to
have that cat what that would be on his
doorstep across the way when I would
come out after doing myself and then now
to hear this dog barking whimpering and
look I think the crazy thing is it took
me a while to notice it and finally I
noticed it and I've know every time I
noticed it now
and I'm just thinking what how long was
i doing this without even noticing that
every time I was masturbating that there
was a dog out there you know a dog was
and I didn't even notice that I was
jerking off and there was it sounds of a
you know a big animal and I don't even
care stop you know I guess it just I
don't know doesn't make me feel bad
about myself but it makes me just like
what the [ __ ] man it makes me think I
don't have a lot of skills you know you
know if an animal's jerking off if I'm
jerking off and an animal is you know
howling and stuff through this a regular
apartment wall or you know it just makes
me think I don't have a lot of skills if
I'm not noticing that so I don't know
maybe I need to meditate more or
something but yeah and then it makes me
think well what if ever you know how far
is this happening like how many animals
within like a you know within a half
block radius are there [ __ ] monkeys
swinging around the chandeliers or birds
chirpin you know are the worms coming up
out of the ground like what the [ __ ]
going on when I you know what's going on
so different times man different times
saying I don't want Santa coming down
the tree cuz it's a you know
embarrassing or down the chimney can't
jerk off without a wolf coming near you
different times man is it the end of
times man if it were the tour if we're
getting close to the end of time the
timing just gonna end there's gonna be
you know a couple months of just you
know some exciting and adventurous
decline so one of my buddies was telling
me the other day he works at a company
they make swords like real my swords and
you know I mean I guess nice swords who
knows dude but he said they've been
selling so many swords he said like
hundreds of times the amount that they
usually do so people are getting ready
people get ready there's a train coming
get your swords brah get a couple nades
and I'm saying text you
when a wall say hey Papa Papa I need a
couple of [ __ ] AIDS bread let's start
that revolución but what else happened
this past weekend and uh I don't know I
don't know that's it man that's it that
was like the most exciting stuff I'll
tell you that I got some upcoming date
and those are at I will be in Omaha
Nebraska coming up and that's selling
pretty good it might sell out soon what
else do we have going on I've got the
Comedy Store in Los Angeles that'll be
December 31st in January first
Omaha funnybone January 11th and 12th
Irvine January 18th 19th and 20th back
at the Addison improv January 25th and
26th February 8th and 9th Columbus Ohio
February 22nd and 23rd Houston improv
March 8th the Wilbur in Boston March 9th
The Borgata Hotel and Casino and March
22nd the San Jose improv and and I'm
gonna be coming Australia in May so you
guys have asked and been so patient and
I'm very excited to be going there it's
crazy I'm gonna be going Australia so
just different times man a lot of stuff
on the platter and I'm excited about it
and I'm excited I'm going home this week
I'm going to see my family you know see
my little nieces and nephews and it's
gonna be fun and just you know try and
be a part of the joy I'm gonna try to
you know whatever is gone in the box of
this year I'm gonna try to finish strong
and put a bow on it you know my life has
been blessed with so many just special
you know special people I've gotten to
meet some special people I mean dude I
was eating cuts a [ __ ] rare you know
damn lamb medallions with dams David
Spade's brother with Joe [ __ ] deer
take himself
dude life sick yeah art in a bad day
Kate and I'm not saying that that makes
somebody special
but I've gotten to meet a lot of
wonderful people from the shows this
year you know I get to go home I get to
see my family you know I love my family
you know they love me you know and I can
be part of other people's joy you know I
can think about well who do I know this
having like a tough time who do I know
that's going through something new
who do I know that maybe I could give a
call to that they would they would think
oh man it's nice that they thought of me
you know who do I know like that and
that's where I'm gonna start my days at
you know I want to just I want to start
my days right there who do I know that
that I could try and care about or have
a better experience with you know who do
I know that I could help today be it a
call an apology
being brave being brave man making some
changes being brave man telling somebody
you love them as being as brave telling
somebody who really you know hey I'd
love to spend some time with you as Bush
it's brave sometimes especially now when
we went here swimming in the dark arts
man
I'm saying that if Voldemort is lurking
but we have we have weapons we have each
other I will tell you this we're get
into some calls we had a lot of we had
some neat calls that came in and let me
take this one right here here we go a
mint from Wisconsin in Wisconsin is very
um well the Packers just lost to the
Bears I will say that dude and I got
drunk one night when Tom who was that
guy Randy Travis no Jim McMahon he used
to be a quarterback for the Chicago
Bears and I got drunk with him
and he told me he used to show his
[ __ ] to uh a friend of his and then
also he was dating he was dating this
little kind of I think it was like a
Jewish lady like a little and she's
always kind of he said that she used to
kind of snack on his butt a little you
know and that's whatever bro you know
we've all been through some stuff but
but and yeah and she had some real tits
on her too I saw but he also told me Jim
McMahon told me that there was a oh he
said one time I said well who was like
kind of you know who was kind of a you
know real wha say that you played with
and he said one time Phil Simms they
were in the Pro Bowl together and Sims
came up to him they both already played
their quarter or whatever and came up to
him was like hey Jim if after the game
you want to throw the ball around or
something on the field you know I'd love
to do that Jim was like [ __ ] that [ __ ]
land I'm gonna get some dang voici you
know but anyway that was kind of a story
that he told me but uh sorry you called
from Wisconsin let me hear [ __ ] word
you know having some pretty steep he's
episodes recently and I thought I could
uh like to get back in you know pick up
the spirits a little bit I've had
a kind of funny story funny for
everybody else but me so I hit some
burgerking they got that deal 10 Nuggets
for a buck now I've heard of a deal
before a deal is something where you're
getting something good this don't seem
really like a deal 10 nah nuggets for a
dollar gotten damn brother this sound
like a real uh this sound like a risk I
found out found out why we don't you
know don't feel the same to yourself man
people will think about this people used
to just poop themselves even before they
had pants you'd be talking to your
friend and they might sneeze and then
just [ __ ] themselves
so homework had to throw my DS away been
having a tough go at it recently
expiring oh if you know you got any
advice for me I can never trust Burger
King again I mean they're fine
establishment I want to throw anything
ahead
you don't throwing shade dude those guys
just took a dollar from you and then you
[ __ ] yourself for them is that business
what kind of business you like to get
involved in huh here's an idea dude
won't you give me 40 bucks and then go
cut your [ __ ] arm off
what a deal nah man it sound like you
got taken advantage of by the king and
they put that guy in the king and he's G
you know the guy had really small legs
and wearing a [ __ ] cape and he's
ginger you know any honestly between me
seems kind of homoerotic and that tells
you right there you eating enough Burger
King bro are you gonna be jerking your
buddy off in a special cape it's that
kind of place I mean at least McDonald's
you know they got all kind of scary
characters they got the [ __ ] burglar
they got the big black guy grimace they
got um who else the [ __ ] they got the
fry guys whatever those dudes are little
French guys or whatever you know what
you know whatever I think they are
who else did it have over there they got
the handicapped girl you know in the
bike or whatever on the on the
wheelchairs but dude Burger King
actually Burger King used to have a
group of kids on the bag and that one
was in a wheelchair was on a skateboard
one of them you know had you know his
eyes were in his net you know back of
his neck or something all kind of wild
[ __ ] so if you trust these people
I say look by Amazon stock that's what
I'm doing I ain't [ __ ] around over
they have a Burger King dollar a pop so
you could you know drive back to why
right back to work and [ __ ] yourself man
you're better than that I think but who
you know I'm not trying to tell you how
to live your life but I will say this
happy holidays to you man and if you
want dude hit up me undies bro me undies
dot-com / weekend dude they got those
deals bro get you a pair of 15% off that
first pair I forgot to tell you guys I
went to Harlan Williams
oh hey Bodie you remember him a Harlan
Williams is a friend amount of comedian
and he was in the movie I know I feel
like I'm name-dropping this whole
episode but he invited me to his
Christmas party and now he was in the
movie what is it
dance not dancing wolves it was armed
oh honey hush no honey i shrunk know
there's something about mary's there's
something about mary's and i'll say this
about mary's did i dated a couple in
high school when i'll say this they give
some real decent [ __ ] that's one
thing about Mary's I don't know about
what the other stuff is but so why went
there in his phone man harlan's knows
how to throw a good party because
everybody brings a 99-cent gift and man
he lives in a fancy place it's like at
the top of the Hollywood Hills you drive
up there and he said damn near who lived
by him
Jodeci lived by him Raven That's So
Raven
you know the bird woman who was in you
know Bill Cosby's you know part when he
was a doctor and you know and we had a
good time but I accidentally started a
fire I was in the kitchen and they had a
man who was drinking because he he got
to spend time away from his wife and
kids for a night and so he was getting
alcohol and he was drinking a bunch of
wine and his teeth was turning gray and
this man apparently he worked as Kermit
the frog's voice he did Kermit the Frog
voice on different films or something we
kept talking to me talking talking and I
was trying to kind of lean I was happy
to listen but I was always I was also
trying to just you know be a part of the
scene and he was talking I think he
might have just been kind of nervous and
I was kind of I was a little bit
lonesome I didn't know anybody really
there so you know it was enjoyable but
he kept talking so I was leaning on the
fire on the hose on the little thing
that starts the stove the igniter and
dude Harlan had about 30 pizzas on the
stove in the box of dominoes next thing
you know bro I guess I hit the light
thing and it lit up
and some guy pushed me kind of out of
the way and he really became a real um
Savior he became a savior and I wasn't
being a savior I was just being somebody
that started a [ __ ] fire I guess but
you know I don't know they say when you
know [ __ ] hits the fan you learn who you
are
you know you're either somebody that's
throwing more [ __ ] at the fan or you're
a diaper you're somebody that helps the
situation and I think I think I was just
kind of neither one I just didn't I mean
I cared but also as a psych [ __ ] man
let's add some fire to this [ __ ] son
you know because when you don't drink
and do drugs sometimes you start looking
for the devil and you want to see
sometimes you want to see the dark
hearts boy sometime I start a vault
immortan baby but thanks for calling man
take care of yourself if you bought
nuggets at that price brah I think he
[ __ ] in yourself is the least of your
worries
we had some calls that came in last week
that were regarding you know there was a
teacher who was texting people for sex
who was texting children for sex women
teacher a female and nude I would give
anything to go back in time dude if Miss
Guerra follow from my junior high school
or whatever would even even today if she
just sent me a ceramic you know mold of
one of her tits boy out [ __ ] my
godson I'd hide my head in the sand and
play with myself you know but but but
now people are sending pictures and
everything and you guys had some calls
and responses your thoughts on that
because I wanted to get what you guys
thought as always the hotline is nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three and you can be a part of what's
going on here here we go hey what's up
field is reverend al fresh from denver
colorado
reverend al fresh thank you for calling
from Denver in Denver if you if you you
know a lot of Dateline episodes they
hide bodies outside of Denver homeward
hey man I just want to let you know I
had an answer to your question about
what's going on with the teachers and
the kids okay thank you for this onward
it's pretty simple man you know
right now men aren't allowed to be men
evolutionary psychology has women
looking for alpha males now I'm not
saying children are alpha males but when
they're in that environment they're
around children that are allowed to be
who they are you know and these little
these young men are the alpha males of
their environment and that triggers
something in the women you know these
teachers that are finding than the grown
men these days because grown man ain't
allowed to be be men you know they're
not allowed to be the alpha males
anymore
Wow it's an interesting take appreciate
you hitting the hotline with that
thought you know there certainly is a
very clear hierarchy in high school of
who are the you know the jocks the
cheerleaders the you know the scientists
the kids selling you know selling weed
the kid you know wearing you know
wearing are you know the kid wearing
like different costumes and [ __ ] to
school and capes they always have some
[ __ ] kid wearing a cape and [ __ ]
yeah there's certainly a hierarchy
that's very evident and yeah I guess I
could see that you know where is like
you get a little bit outside of high
school when suddenly you can't if you're
not playing a football or a sport you
can't even really to prove that you're a
man that much anymore that is that
mainstream media is glorifying for sure
you know if you're a hunter Europe they
you know may they say you're a piece of
[ __ ] if you're you know if you just want
to have a wife that stays at home they
say you're like a slave owner you know
if you just you know there's no but
there's yeah there's a man can't spank
his kids anymore without going to jail
it's tough I guess that's interesting
that maybe in in the school system these
teachers they see oh wow you know little
Sherman over there gots two trophies
from the track meet and all the [ __ ]
love him I bet he would be
special for me it's interesting
interesting take thank you for hitting
the hotline with that let's take another
call here we go
what's up feel the charge y'all driving
uber in Boston right now with sup taj
from uber toss out there on the mean
streets homework you were talking about
why teachers are getting with students
now more than ever and you know i mean
we're all more sexual than ever all of
us are more sexual than ever miss these
hot mama teachers they can have those
hottest dude in school now these
teachers they go over the line man i
hasn't seen as over like 21 like these
teachers are in school like to the seven
years ago this chick was swinging on the
monkey bars and you know making bad
decisions yeah i guess i mean you know
yeah they're not that far removed from
school maybe they're still living
vicariously out some of their school
time they don't want to grow up
[Music]
yeah people with especially with the
internet and this is something even we
notice with the chris hansen episode is
that there's this line that's like it
still feels it feels like a safe it
feels like a fictional area then when
I'm playing on the internet it doesn't
feel like feels like once I close my
computer none of that is gonna affect my
real life it feels like a video game so
I'm sure a lot of these teachers on
these chat rooms and different things
maybe that's the feeling there again oh
this is just a video game
you know I'm a sitting send a little
Jeremy over there a picture it is slick
wallet you know I'm gonna show them the
old brown-eyed girl and I'm [ __ ] magic
you know
snapchat window
yeah let's take another call that came
in homework hey Lance from West Texas
love the podcast man but I just wanted
to answer a question you're wondering
wild and teachers now are hitting on
kids young men and I think it's because
the skin teens you know he's got a kid a
guy back there with that dick hanging
out you know on that side with the
skinny jeans been teachers you know they
get them pheromones going and [ __ ] no oh
yeah oh
you see a little bit young teachers
women they want everybody wants to [ __ ]
something that's kind of you know
youthful looking that's nature there's
something inside of you you want to [ __ ]
something or at least four men you know
you want your you know you want to
a young woman makes you think you can
have a young child the baby is gonna be
healthy
all of that is limbic as inside of our
brains that's in our history so yeah man
I bet maybe that's just what's starting
to happen to women but that dick print I
guess you could have a special pair of
pants on you got the skinny jeans dude
and I had that ap that adult penis since
I was I don't even know second I saw my
dick it was the Saint my dick bit my
sock same size in the whole life adult
size like a big snicker and I can't
imagine what my teachers thought you
know even them to changing my diapers at
the baby center that lady must have been
like Jesus Christ then they usually they
used to put one diaper on me and then
pull my dick over to the side out of the
original diaper and put another little
diaper on my dick
you know and that's just is that dark
magic or is that mother nature we don't
know but it's yeah I'm sure if you're
going in there and men are looking
sexier with tight pants it could
influence a woman some see yeah it's an
interesting thought man I appreciate the
call let's take one more in response to
what was happening that was a Kentucky
teacher who just got busted texting one
of her students and sending new D's and
stuff like that and booty pics and you
know you know spread legged photos and
and titties homework hey so yeah Lucas
from Austin Texas
hey hey Lucas I appreciate you reaching
down here from Austin and dude I was
just doing some you know I was doing
yoga today and I do yo Gogh my offer
YouTube and the one I do is called yoga
with Adriene and it's usually done in
Austin Texas
but um work
hey so right now you're talking about
why these female teachers are [ __ ]
around with these with these children
and why not
yeah and that's true maybe and when you
say that Lukas even about children you
know it makes me wonder maybe they want
children but they don't want to have
them they don't want to mess their
bodies up so they're like oh well I'll
just you know I'll have a child in my
body but just for a little bit just with
sex and not with you know gestation
homeward
well I think if we take a look I was
born in 88 so I'm 30 this generation I
guess you know mine and younger and
whatnot pretty much I think they're
acting like children I mean everybody's
acting my children nobody wants to have
kids and a lot of people are building
forts they're doing forts in the living
room you know a lot of child things are
sticking around and I don't know I think
it's always relate you know you're under
30 and you think you're kind of still a
kid you see a long life Eddy so you get
blends which is weirdly blender
especially early 20s early early
twenties that's pretty much worth that
they see no age difference between them
and a 16 year old 15 year old because
then the 15 year olds they're grown up
they're der Goltz they're they know
what's up already so the memory ecology
is going up it's meeting in the middle
Wow hmm you know when I was when I was
young we I used to ride the school bus
one time I was at school and dot wall
had to take me home on the bus and
somebody had told me called me a dildo
at school oh no some kid said would you
know what a dildo is and I didn't know
but I said I do know what it is dude you
know and then III and I didn't know and
I felt ashamed and the kids made fun of
me to other boys and then when I got on
the bus I called the teeth the lady said
something I called her a [ __ ] dildo
and I had to go to the principal and my
principal had a brown tooth dude so you
know great guy but at the same time I'm
like [ __ ] man you know brush your teeth
a little
you know maybe somebody paddled this
dude riding in the tooth but anyway you
know sometimes you know [ __ ] I don't you
know I'm talking about but I'll say this
man is that I think there's something to
that
nobody people don't want to grow up now
and there's this fictional there's this
world online this fictional universe
even with video games and you know
avatars and all that where it's all you
can commingle you can dude I've had
people send me a message on Instagram
that are underage women and gay young
men say what you know trying to holler
at me and I say what the [ __ ] my say
look I can't he I can't even communicate
with you even in any facet there's no
there's no hell lot there's no you know
you know suggestions for young guys
there's none of that you know I'm not
playing in that universe but yeah man I
I could see that I could see how people
get you know why not it's just it's an
online world where anything can happen
and then I think also if maybe if
parents aren't able to parent their kids
as much fathers aren't able to be
fathers as much then these young women
they don't look as older men maybe as
fathers so you have all right you know
like our vice versa it's like you see
you know everybody yeah just kind of all
blends together and especially more than
online universe that's what I'm thinking
is like if you're in this you know
there's this game people are playing
night star something what is it um where
people do make up fake characters and
they fight each other
it's called ah I don't final fan of it
it is it's huge though all the kids play
it but if you're on there you know long
as your avatar looks decent and I think
women want to strike back a lot of these
[ __ ] are like it they want to go to
prison
snapped a lot of lot of you know while
women they just want to be on an episode
of snapped that's their dream
you know I just wanna yeah you know
Aileen Wuornos remember her she was the
one who was dating that little boy
shalikashvili or whatever out of um
Hawaii and dude that was the only one
you ever heard of when I was growing up
these you know a senior citizen woman
and now here you have real it's popular
everyday dude makes me want to find a
damn time machine why go back in school
I wear cologne every day
Robbie stuff in my pants bra with a
couple of tube socks
dude that long was not them little
anchor ones [ __ ] that that's the
weirdest guy who somebody who stuffs
their saw their pants with socks and
does it with an ankle sock you little
[ __ ] throw a couple tubes in there you
know take your chances
but everybody's acting like children
maybe now it's like especially maybe if
people don't have as much faith and
religion and they're thinking there's no
afterlife and stuff like that anymore
that maybe they're just like oh well let
me just live here let me just dance with
the devil all night long they'd rather
just live the consequences out here
because they think it doesn't matter
just a thought
different times ma'am let's take another
call here that came in the hotline is
nine eight five six six four nine five
zero three and I want to say this for
those of you listening to this through
the laughable iPhone app we've got
something really special to offer you
it's a chance to buy our get in their
shirt on sale for the holidays in a
totally new way if you allow push
notifications from laughable you're
going to get a link to that shirt on
your phone on your home screen right now
just tap on that alert and the listing
will pop up pretty cool right you can go
to the listing in other ways to
laughable has put links to it on the
media player screen for this episode in
the episode description and
front-and-center on its discover
recommendations you can't miss it
you'll be amazed at how fast and simple
it is to buy through laughable way less
of a headache than going through a
website I'm also going to have a couple
of new shirts
the road to the strap goes through the
rat that one will be coming out this
week as well it won't get to you about
Christmas but it's a nice shirt we've
been you know putting it together for a
while and in the episode you can go vote
too on for Fighter and the kid if you're
a fighter in the kid listener and
they're having guest of the year on the
opportunity for somebody to win that
strap but yes laughable we're excited to
be experimenting with laughable to find
new ways to reach you guys with special
offers and to connect what you're
hearing me say with what you can do in
the laughable app we think it's the
future so I hope you will help us invent
that future by placing your order today
yes check out the laughable app it's a
great way to listen to any podcast I've
ever been on and also to this past
weekend but they have a new technology
where if somebody talks about a product
or something on that they're selling a
podcaster then a link can be right there
in that moment so you can go and check
out that check it out that way in real
time as you listen pretty cool
I'm also on Michael Rosenbaum has a
podcast and you can check it out I just
did an episode with him what is it
called rosin BAM and he was Lex Luthor's
Luthor sorry
inside of you is the podcast you can go
check that out let's listen to another
couple calls that came in here here we
go what's good Theo this is Billy from
Addison Texas I work at the Addison
improv and I just helped you out with
your merch table when you came through
and he tipped me out nicely I just want
to say thanks for that man oh you're
welcome Billy yeah I had a good time in
Addison man and I'll see you there again
soon in a couple of weeks I was a little
overwhelmed man it was it was a long day
but I'm feeling a little more relaxed
now onward I also want to say I'm 241
days sober Wow dude that's awesome man I
appreciate you sharing that man that may
me you just made me feel so good man
you know and I hate to say that I feel
good cuz it's not about me but you made
me feel
oh joy man you just in one second bro
you made me feel joy that's crazy and
not not joy for me but I feel just joy
for you you know cuz that's a confident
thing to say man Oh word you've helped
me stay sober just caring about your
story and your journey and all that man
I appreciate it not to be a debbie
downer but my mom died when I was one so
I can relate to some of the things you
mentioned about having intimacy issues
and all that I mean all those
unfortunate it's just dope to hear that
someone else deals with similar issues
man so keep doing what you're doing and
I'll see you in January do Gang Gang
Gang Gang man well I'm sorry to hear
about your mother dude that makes me
feel kind of sad you know but I'll tell
you this I I do remember meeting you
short hair guy white guy and I bet she'd
be really proud of you dude you know I
bet she'd be proud of your sobriety
she'd be proud of um you know you know
you're a handsome young guy I thought no
homo bro you know I'm staying I'm still
chasing you know females and that
struggling to do it but that's what I'm
doing um but I bet she'd be really
really proud of you dude
you know she obviously created a very
nice young man and uh and I'm sure
you'll see her again one day and she can
let you know just how proud of you all
she is but thanks man
[ __ ] I now have to pay you better next
time you helped out with the merch man
damn you really put me on the spot there
boy it really put me on the spot but I
might bring one of them lollies Brian
one of them face lollies if we got any
seniors out there we can heat them up in
the crowd but merry Christmas to you man
and and thank you for helping and thank
you for that call it was just a nice
thing for you to do you didn't have to
call and say that and you did onward
let's take another call here here we go
what's up Bo my name is Ryan calling
from Atlanta Georgia she's not done
listening to your attachment theory
archives hey Ryan from Atlanta thank you
for calling in brother home word and how
you were saying that you wanted to add a
little more diversity for
you know black artists in the exact
nature and they never hit back you know
I'm a black I'm black you know I really
think it doesn't matter you just keep
doing your thing man
you shouldn't have to satisfy
everybody's opinions on whether or not
your podcast is diverse or what not to
do do you you know and you know if the
opportunity does come where you know you
get you know more black people or
whatever rates on your podcast then
that's cool you know and the comment
that you said about being afraid of
black people you know I wouldn't blame
you especially if the fact that you know
you grew up in Louisiana you know as a
lot of black people there and they would
jump jump to you and beat you up [ __ ] I
would be afraid to you know so just be
honest always be honest you know you
know people just don't want to be honest
and everybody obviously in this culture
is offended about everything that's
pretty much all I want that says you
keep doing what you're doing
I enjoy your podcast it gets me through
my workday hey you are hilarious and
clever so like I said keep doing your
thing man love you
well thanks for the message man that's
nice you to say I appreciate it you know
that's nice you to say some of those
things I appreciate you listening to the
podcast yeah so no I guess I do feel
yeah I guess I mean I don't like force
diversity either you know but I do feel
I don't know it's crazy like I don't
want to be somebody who doesn't offer
opportunities to you know my black
friends or black entertainers you know
or you know what
I appreciate you saying the be honest
part you know I mean there's times like
where you know when when people started
really looking especially at race like
in Hollywood and like in the past two
years there's been like a lot of you
know a lot of stuff about race a lot of
conversation about it and I talk about
it a lot but it did make me start to
think like what some of my circles are
like and you know if I do have
prejudices or I do have feet you know
like I have you know leftover fears from
experiences when I was young with black
kids or you know being afraid I guess I
think I was probably afraid of
everything you know and I guess
sometimes I you know I wish that I could
be you know it well it just made me
think like if I want to have more of an
experience with black people in my life
then I have to at least try and make
more efforts in that space it made me
think like oh wow
usually when I have a comedy show like
I'll put some black friends on it here
and there it doesn't matter I don't
think like oh I got to have a black guy
on the show but sometimes I'll ask some
of my comedian friends who were great
comedians who happened to be different
you know race or ethnicity than me or
gender even to be on my shows but it
made me think oh sometime you know I
could probably take an opener with me on
the road that is a black guy and because
I could help a little bit in some way by
putting more money and opportunity into
the black community and I and I don't
mean that in a way like I have any power
control or anything like that I just
meant it in the simple way that like oh
wow the openers that I've always taken
I've always been like for like a full
week and I've always been a white guy I
think one time I took a well I guess I
don't know but it just made me I guess
it made me think I could be a little bit
more conscious of thinking like well I
do know that in the history of time in
America that black people have had less
financial support and have had a tough
road and what can I do some time not in
a way where it's like oh look at me
watch me help or watch me do this but
what is a way that I could you know just
try and be more a part of the solution
of like well let me give let me at least
try and be more conscious of the fact
that if I have some opportunities to
just be more conscious of the fact that
I could give them to black friends and
black comedians I guess so I don't know
I guess some of the stuff I don't know
what I'm talking about a little but but
it's made me a little bit more conscious
man just the past couple years is made
me think
dude there's times where it's like am i
am i racist you know there's definitely
I'd you know I'd always say no like I
always would be like oh I have you know
I have black friends I'd black comedian
friends you know I work with I don't
ever you know like be like all knock I
don't want to be around these people
because they're black or I don't have
any but it does make it did make me
think more about like what fears do I
have what like stereotypes and
prejudices and in some places they're
different man it's so it's so crazy like
in Los Angeles I don't have as much fear
and stuff when I see black kids out here
black people out here black friends out
here in New Orleans it's it that's just
scarier sometimes and I guess it's best
because there are some areas and just
like there are white area do there's
white areas where it's like man when I
go out in some of those areas like you
know I feel scared you know when I get
into some real severe areas of like I
don't want to say I guess yeah like
redneck type [ __ ] you know like real
rest [ __ ] makes me scared
and I guess actually some of that
feeling is kind of I guess the same
really it's just
it makes me feel like there's just more
of a sense of carelessness around and
but yeah I mean I think one thing that
I've noticed that has been good about
the past few years of people talking
more about race and thinking more about
it
is that it makes me honestly think about
it it keeps it on the forefront of my
mind and it makes me sad to think that
like I you know I grew up with kids who
you know I wish that they would have had
more opportunity you know it makes me
sad you know they had this one kid Devin
he was a good friend of mine growing up
and he we used to have fun together and
we ride our bikes and we would you know
go eat you know we go get plums and
stuff from the ANP and eat them and you
know get like fish and meeting of do
fishing and
and he all you know he always made I
don't know I think we were kind of the
same a little bit in our own I don't
know we just had some I got I don't know
what I'll give her at his friends and
and he ended up he got convicted of
murder he tried to murder somebody a
couple years ago and went to jail for it
I think he did actually was in a group
of people that murdered somebody and
like the green something hotel outside
of Covington Louisiana and and it just
makes me wonder you know it was sad a
lot of like kids did not have a lot of
infrastructure around them when I was
young you know but now we know but I
appreciate you saying that that you know
about forest diversity and then it's
interesting cuz a lot of black shows
don't include it you know it seems like
that yeah the force diversity thing
isn't helpful even though I would love
to see some straight-up real vatos and
[ __ ] mexicanos in the NB a dog come
on you telling me the Lakers got all
these fans bro and they don't have one
dude named Umberto [ __ ] shooting six
pointers from half-court we're in
[ __ ] Dickies every game bro come Oh
papa um but now appreciate you saying
that I appreciate you saying about being
honest missin time I I just need to hear
that and just feel okay with you know
trying to figure out who I am as I talk
cuz I don't you know I I want to be I
mean one thing that has been nice and
when I like my life I don't think about
white privileges I've had the privilege
of seeing a lot more black opportunity
in my lifetime you know you know when I
see some kids start to make it in young
dudes and their black guys and and not
in a selfish way but man it makes me
feel good you know cuz I didn't see that
growing up you know they had dude they
had kids you know I mean you had to do
they have one dude [ __ ] janitor just
and I told about to do last week that
dude they named him [ __ ] janitor
maybe his parents just knew like I'm
making sure he gets employed here
locally
but there wasn't as much opportunity you
know and now there is more and some of
the stuff that we deal with in America
sometimes just gonna take time you know
you need a couple more generations but I
think that you know Donnell Rollins said
it well that we're getting out of that
thing this excuse culture where people
want to be just excuse babies you know
sit around and because if they want to
do that that's their life man go have
that life if that's what you want you
know no matter what who you are but yeah
but anyway man I appreciate the the call
sorry I had a such a long diatribe on
that um but you know it's nice of you to
call because sometimes I think you know
I get sometimes I think well what and
sometimes I do think it's like you know
that a white person could never really
know what it's like to live in a black
environment and grow up in black in
America you know you could never really
know you could never really know and it
[ __ ] looks fun bruh dude I've had two
friends and woman's black friends that
were killed by other black men over the
past 20 years and and I'm not saying
that's fun on my saying that's good but
dude getting being white gets a little
boring there's no there's not I mean
there's guns but there's not you know
there's not as many you're not as fast
you don't get to do as many sports
that's fun you can't [ __ ] dunk as
well you can't be in the band as good
you know you don't get to play that big
drum you got to play the [ __ ] a
little clarinet like dude I think by
people right now have so has such a
great opportunity in America it seems
like but [ __ ] do I know Brian
but thanks for listening man and thanks
for calling in I appreciate it the
hotline as always as nine eight five six
six four nine five zero three we have
this right here that I want to tell you
about it's the smart setup guide
business building 101 and there's a man
named Martin who does all of who handles
all of my social media and has helped
really transform some of my and has
helped some of my business ideas become
reality
ladies and if you own a business or
thinking about starting one or have a
friend or family member that is this
course is a hundred percent absolutely
for you it's easy to understand easy to
implement online video course
it breaks down need-to-know information
that will save you massive amounts of
time money and energy building your
business in just 2.5 hours you will
develop a pro level understanding of how
logo design and brand identity can make
or break your business the best way to
build your website and online store how
to outrank your competition on Google
social media marketing and how to secure
new clients and maintain them long term
the course is created by Martin O'Neill
owner of drastic graphics who has over a
decade's worth of experience working
with some of the biggest brands Joe
Rogan this past weekend fighter in the
kid it's a perfect holiday gift for
entrepreneur business owner or ambitious
person that you know or yourself for the
month of December get a 30% discount
visit smart setup guide dot-com and use
code Theo at checkout that is smart set
up guide.com
and use code theo at checkout and that
is a real deal man i think that thing is
a real deal it's like six videos it's
two and a half hours of information
his tutorials martin does a great job
let's take a another call here here we
go
hey CEO what's up this is our Thomasson
been listening to a podcast for like 500
year now i just was listening to you
talking about possibly not doing guest
spots anymore and it's more to say that
I I personally have a guest your guest
interviews and are my favorite part I
just think you're putting a little too
much pressure on yourself to be
interviewer when all anybody really
wants well at least I want to see and I
think other people want to see it's just
your personality meeting someone else is
not necessarily an interview
Wow man I appreciate that thank you for
that yes sometimes I just don't know
what I'm doing with it you know it's
hard to be like it's exciting to talk to
some of these people but it's hard
because you don't want to you know I
want to engage I want to be I want to
care about what I'm talking about I want
to be engaged with them you know I guess
maybe I should think about it a little
bit more but thank you for saying that
yeah I mentioned last episode that I was
thinking about not having guests or
maybe just doing them occasionally and I
think I am going us to at least get down
and doing them occasionally or not every
week especially with King and the sting
starting up but some of it also is just
a stress man I've been feeling so
stressed and uh and I've been trying to
relax more and take a little bit better
care of myself and I feel like I'm
starting to and so I'm hoping that I'm
will start feeling a little bit better
like a little damn you know just like a
newborn little [ __ ] baby lion but
thank you for that let's take another
call this about guess as well it says
hey do was Brandon from Ellensburg
Washington here's my one-year-old
oh you got a damn one-year-old huh hell
yeah boy that thing's still got a little
bit of scent on him you know what I'm
saying
my buddy dude I say this it's kind of
vulgar but he had a newborn baby and it
still smelled enough like the old you
know what I'm saying hoo-ha he used to
kind of you know he'd get a couple hits
at a baby and then you know run out of
the baby's room and rub one out in the
restroom by himself
nothing crazy you know but so you know
different people do different stuff
let's hear more podcast every Monday and
Wednesday morning but I wanted to tell
you that I'm all in for you doing less
yes I love to guess do you have on you
have good guest interviewer well but we
enjoyed the individual podcast a lot
more you talked about some good or
fireman so you know what are they a mine
you know what my yang Goering man thank
you for calling in and congratulations
this might be your baby's first
Christmas I'm not sure
and Christmas coming up but uh I hope
that's warm to you guys and you get to
spend time with your loved one there all
right let's take another we got another
call right here this is uh this says
it's humorous hombre man I was calling
about one of the best or worst weekend
this is only Saturday at 1:00 a.m. right
now and it's definitely gonna be one of
the lowest point I thought I would just
call you because I had to have someone
to call man okay thank you for calling
we'll get into your emergency right now
now the best or worst weekend we're
getting back into that if you have a
best or worst weekend that occurred for
you and don't give us no [ __ ]
weekend you know like your nephew you
know got a rash or something like that
or somebody won a couple of dollars at
the track or whatever or you guys
[ __ ] been you know watching videos of
Bichons online or whatever make sure
it's something legitimate and you could
always leave those on the hotline nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three homeward I was just at Waffle
House I go there all the time oh damn I
love waffles bro they have raisin bread
how in the [ __ ] more people don't have
raisin bread man what a crazy person
thought of that dude you know what I'm
saying somebody must have been with some
[ __ ] dope or weed or just acid or
something or some fruit acid because
they're sitting around some bread and
they're like hey guys are one I'm hot
some [ __ ] raisins in this match I
mean wow people are amazing let's hear
more cooks know my order okay so you a
walk you were regular you will Waffle
House a regular bra more and the cook in
there he's kind of a sketchy dude we all
smoked a little poppet I think he's
doing a little extra a little extra of
the dark dark magic and whatnot oh he
might be on that simple syrup you know
what I'm saying are that simpleton
scissor he might be on that straight
[ __ ] cocaine man I worked at a place
one time to do did so much cocaine he
did more than his paycheck
what the [ __ ] dude you got to do a
little less than your paycheck you got
to save $40 to eat during the week you
know get you a couple of you know gay
gay station
dogs more and man a police officer can't
came rolling into the parking lot and I
gave him a little courtesy whistle
because he was out of his car obviously
up to no good
and I didn't know that the police
officers window was down and so he
directly drove over there as a
consequence to me whistling mmm
and then relayed that information to the
gentleman that he's been arrested for
two ounces of marijuana I know I can
never go back to that Waffle House again
man yeah I wouldn't recommend going back
I'd find another Waffle House where I'd
find a huddle house or I just find a bad
[ __ ] I don't mind using a little bit of
you know they don't mind heating up that
griddle around midnight but jam man I
mean you owe them an apology I would see
if you could you know contribute to the
court costs or something give them one
hundred and fifty dollar gift
certificate maybe two Dick's Sporting
Goods or something it sounds like there
might be a Dick's around you know it
Dick's Sporting Goods around you guys
usually those if a Waffle House they got
a Dick's Sporting Goods within about 10
miles um [ __ ] man
yeah you [ __ ] up you snitchin at least
you didn't eat [ __ ] ten nuggets for a
dollar and [ __ ] yourself bro the guy
also if he's gonna smoke dope he should
do it in a you know more of a regulated
area you know I mean he could probably
[ __ ] vapor eight over about a grill
and just blow the [ __ ] into the [ __ ]
grilled cheeses so I think it's 50/50 I
think give some responsibility because
you tried to intervene you tried to help
if you didn't do anything maybe he would
still be capable you know and still
living or outside of jail but he's two
ounces of [ __ ] weed damn dude I won't
rolled in a Waffle House one time and
try to get him to start a softball team
at night and one of the [ __ ]
assistant managers beat my ass so you
know sometimes those people are up for
you know new ideas and sometimes they
are all right let's take another call
onward but good luck man and thank you
for calling to get it off your chest
as always the hotline is a place you can
get something off your chest nine eight
five six six four nine five zero three
let's hear a call that came in worst
weekend actually homeward and I just
don't know what to do
all right so I'm 23 oh okay sorry this
isn't a worst weekend this says sexting
okay onward all right so I'm 23 I'm
[ __ ] a 39 year old oh you damn you
should go back to high school and man
it's what it sounds like more she's got
a husband but he had a horrible accident
I know it sounds [ __ ] up but he is
recovering from being paralyzed and they
had that [ __ ] in years and now she's
sexting me and wants to [ __ ] me but she
lives in Fort Lauderdale and I was
[ __ ] Champa so it's a little bit of a
problem and I'm a mind along for [ __ ]
her no right because I mean the dude has
a limp dick
that's not muscle I mean I just met her
on a plane and she now she wants to [ __ ]
me and I didn't even have her number
well you didn't ask for her number
that's true but you have some part in it
you know I engaged one time with this
lady just about 13 years ago and I think
we ended up making love in a hotel room
really quickly cuz I'm that type of dude
I make love really quickly brah some
people run our milling around in the
cooter and all of that dude I'm out um I
brought the my dick has sleep apnea or
something you know or arm what does it
call when you just fall asleep when you
don't know what's going on um
I think is just sheer ignorance or
something no it's a Pierre father had it
our old librarian had it just a nice
assist a you know you're just talking to
somebody in a plug and suddenly they one
of the Seven Dwarfs they the sleepy one
and they just nod out you're like damn
[ __ ] Gerald don't give a damn when
I'm talking about
but anyway dude if you do have some part
you're communicating with you can't
blame it all on the woman you sat next
to her right you guys ain't now you know
she has a paralyzed husband
you know he's lized a lot of people call
that lies and when I was growing up they
had this dude he was always fresh and
man is black guy and he had heat both of
his legs he was paraplegic and they
braided his legs around each other you
know his legs probably made about four
pounds each just a long string a bone
and a little bit of skin and you know
five toes on each and they would braid
them [ __ ] kind of cornrow his legs a
little bit because he was I think he was
in like a [ __ ] gang or something but
anyway man what I'm saying is this you
didn't paralyze the guy the guy has a
wife she is she's walking out on her man
she's trying to get some sexual outside
of her man and he's lized up I would do
what I would do is I would talk to the
guy I would say look guy you know I'd
love to help out around the house you
know don't tell him that you're gonna
try and have sex with his wife but I
would let him know there's a way to do
it I think where you can be a part of
the solution for them because he
probably feels bad he might like to know
that his wife is being pleasured somehow
because maybe he just loves her enough
and he just wants her to feel good and
be had to have some sexual pleasure even
if it's not him dude I tell you that I
bet 30% of guys would love for some dude
to [ __ ] roll through their
neighborhood like the Schwan's guy or
Swanson's or whatever and drop off some
[ __ ] frozen [ __ ] meat every couple of
months
you know it's wild it's like if you need
a massage you know you have somebody
come and make all your muscles feel good
except that last muscle that crotch it's
totally fine and go pay somebody hundred
fifty dollars to rub your wife's back or
something and put some olive oil on her
neck or some you know [ __ ] peppermint
drops in her [ __ ] or whatever and
call it a massage but the second you get
to the part where somebody's you know
going in or doing crotch work or
whatever you know giving you [ __ ]
then everything gets you know erroneous
so I would approach the dude like a man
bra okay yeah it's not your fault he's
into that he's that he's lized up and
you did something to him unless you hit
him with something and I don't know you
sound like you might have been doing you
know I don't know what you've been up to
dude honestly I'm being judgmental but
who knows I'll let me listen a little
bit more what you said homeward from
being paralyzed they [ __ ] in years and
now she's sexting me and wants to [ __ ]
me but she lives it for last Lauderdale
and I was [ __ ] chance but dude Fort
Lauderdale to Tampa that's not that far
dude at least go do it and be a helpful
person you're [ __ ] that guys in a
wheel chair how long I would take him to
get to Fort Lauderdale to Tampa probably
about 200 hours or 300 hours dude what's
it a couple hours for you you got all
your legs and a vehicle and [ __ ] you
over here bitching you're the one is
paralyzed so I'm just saying man if
you're gonna be helpful be helpful you
know but I would try and find some way
to discuss it with the man and see if
you can offer that service in a loving
way because he may want his wife to be
taken care of as well gang gang man but
good luck out there and if you drive
over there wear your seatbelt dude
wouldn't be crazy if you ended up
getting [ __ ] peel eyes doubt and now
this ladies just collect them
you know paraplegics it at the house and
going and it's just you know the next
dick is on its way and that dude gets
hit by a dang you know dump truck or
something or you know somebody's moving
a big elevator and it falls off oh you
know a pallet on to the car whatever
okay but be safe man all right love you
okay let's hear another call that came
in homeward what's up Co what's up Seth
from Virginia Beach and my boy Tony
brothers is over there in Virginia Beach
and he has men for hope I think is his
charity they got a great organization
and he's one of my favorite NBA referees
over there homework have some thoughts
tough guy call him in about being you
know anonymous with your sobriety you
know he has like what a five percent
success rate right they had a gentleman
I called in last week I've been talking
about being sober and and why I was
sober that's what I've been talking
about why I'd found my
way into the meetings and stuff and uh
and he called in and said that I should
not talk about some of it in that I
shouldn't talk about in that facet I
should talk about sobriety but but I
shouldn't talk about the program of AAA
itself because we are not supposed to
talk about that homeward and in your
situation if your people get sober
staying sober
sounds like you have more of a success
rate than you know what we call just a
business at the end of the day na na CA
junk foods anonymous sex addicts
anonymous it's all just for some sort of
money don't you think in a way donation
baskets packed around you no no that's
true the nation basket passes around but
I'll say this man I've been involved
with a lot of different environments
where there's a basket that goes around
the room or the opportunity to donate
I've never seen one I've never seen them
collect enough money in one of those
rooms to do much and there's never you
know I can't it doesn't seem like a
place that makes any money to me that it
all goes right back into the program in
fact it's the only place I've ever
witnessed miracles happen or in in some
of the rooms where I go to be a part of
a sober group the only I mean I've seen
miracles happen and uh and that's one of
the things that keeps me going back and
being entertained so yeah I would never
say that I firm from my experience I've
not seen any of that be about money in
fact I feel like I wish the government
didn't have any hands on it but I wish
that they would give them a huge stipend
every year just to help out but maybe
but the some of those programs they're
self-supporting they are self-supporting
you know and that's what makes them
continue to function it's a some of
those programs are really really
exceptional man have blown my mind the
way that they operate and the lives that
they save but you know it's the rules
say in the program you're not supposed
to talk about it at the level of press
radio and film and I guess podcast is
radio
I mean I think of it as like a journal
really kind of like a wild journal but
maybe some people is different but uh
but thank you for calling in um
onward let's take another call I do this
is a case in Texas not going to use my
real name because I'm about to get into
some sensitive [ __ ] but damn a K from
Texas Blaine
I'll work I just want to let you know I
appreciate the podcast and take a lot
out of this as well thank you for that
anyway you're welcome man thank you guys
for being here
do you know the two-year anniversary of
the podcast is in like a couple days
December 19th
three days so next G next week's episode
which all the tape from my brother's
house in Louisiana
it'll be two years so we're calling in
just because I don't really have anyone
else to tell I almost slept with my
coworker after the Christmas party on
last week
damn by that's it's fun I think those
kind of environments that's one thing I
do miss about drinking is you know and
more things could happen you know you
can't be too so when you sober you can't
but you know you know fall asleep on a
Xerox and wake up with you you know
you're [ __ ] some lady's printer you
know you can't do it like that
so you gotta have more reasoning behind
what you're doing what happened oh we're
kind of conflicted about tests did
seeing a girl for a few years she's out
of town and decisions were made and they
were going back home with her but he
didn't do anything and I don't know I
had a weird crossroads in my life don't
know what the [ __ ] I want I don't know
if my girls the one don't think that
this this girl I work with is the one
either but she was there and just
looking pretty good with them I could
smack you know oh you snack a dactyl boy
I'm gonna have [ __ ] plus a lot of pus
homework so hey thanks for listening
don't know what to want to expect but
yes No there we go here we go man and
sometimes you just gotta take that edge
off and share that and it sounded like
to me when I was listening to you
something did probably happen when y'all
went back to our house you know but
whether something
did or didn't the reality beneath a lot
of it is that you know you're probably
feeling some remorse you're uncertain
about your own relationship here's the
thing I would tell your girlfriend this
if you need if you're thinking about
telling her I mean I can heavily relate
to this situation man in its heart
there's a lot of influences today that
make you wonder you and the should you
settle down are we settling down what's
going on can I do this you know it's
hard it's crazy it's like you know I
could love somebody to the end of the
world and then you know still just have
something inside of me sometimes that
make some poor choices or that messes up
and it's hard to live with both of those
things to be both of those things at the
same time and some of my friends are
like that and they embrace it a lot
better some of them are like well I'm
just gonna cheat on my spouse and just
you know keep that burden to myself and
that's just how I'm gonna be sometimes
it doesn't mean I'm not gonna love my
spouse it doesn't mean I'm not gonna
raise my family and and be a good diet
other people say well I would never do
that I want my home to be sacred and
that's and then you know it's different
types of people that are able to handle
different types of things one of my
friends says dude quit lyin
I quit lying on myself and pretending
like I was gonna be able to be a man
that could do a family or be able to be
a successful like you know have that
type of environment and I finally
realized no I'm just gonna be the type
of man that's gonna make some poor
choices sometimes and this is I'm never
gonna be able to stop like being
entertained by other women and stuff
like that so I've heard a lot of my
friends share a lot of these things the
thing that you know I don't know I think
they always say that the truth will set
you free and I wouldn't tell someone
something if they don't need to hear it
though sometimes you know if so if it's
just gonna hurt somebody's feelings you
don't have to tell them you know you can
tell somebody that you're struggling
with y'all's how you're feeling though
you know it's brave to do that thing to
do that and I've struggled with that man
you know just knowing like [ __ ] and my
what if I can't do this what if I can't
you know love somebody forever or if I
if I already know or think in my head
that I'm gonna make a mistake or I'm
gonna date somebody else or sleep around
on my wife or girlfriend and you know
and those burdens are hard to carry man
I've carried him and it's you know it's
painful to carry that stuff around
because you know the earth I mean you
know you're hurting somebody else's
feelings but they don't know about it
but you're also just hurting your you
know you kind of hurtin yourself in
those instances um so but I think you
know we might get to a level of humanity
where some of the stuff of the committed
relationship kind of not it devolves but
it just it evolves into like what's
actually if we're capable or not cuz
there's people that you know we're that
we're living up to this ideal that are
trying to live up to an ideal of a
family this idea of a family and a
relationship in their head that they
know that they can't or just they're not
ready and they're trying to and that's
what I found for myself sometimes I just
you know but but don't just don't be too
hard on yourself man it doesn't mean
that you're a bad person you know it
just means that this is something that's
going on that's made you some aware of
that you may need to communicate better
about it or you may need to really have
a come-to-jesus to call talk with
yourself or with a therapist but I wish
you well man and you know if you're not
gonna tell your spouse or something
about it you could or your girlfriend
you could at least also just go and be
very loving to them in some way you know
just as though just as when you know if
you make a mistake in one direction you
can make an unmistakeable any know that
you love them or that you care you know
but it's hard man it's hard to be you
know away from people that you love you
know and it's hard to have them not in
your life sometimes but
you know because you don't even know
what kind of life you're living or what
kind of life you want to live or
sometimes up for me I don't even know if
I already am living the life I want to
live and I'm just constantly
second-guessing myself thank you for
your call brother merry Christmas to you
man and just give you girl a hug and you
know and try to communicate when you can
let's take one more call and then we'll
shut it down what's up yeah what's up
lair homeward just calling because I am
been going through something for about
like three years now you've been going
through something like what a maze
that's a bad joke more good three years
where I know for a fact 100% fact I'm
not gay I'm not in command do you might
not be gay bruh you know but you never
know well if you say you're not you're
not dude you know what I'm saying I
thought I might be gay sometimes but I
don't want some other dude in my
freaking house all the time so you know
let's hear more love love vagina I don't
know if it's beautiful dude is
definitely some you know a lot of it's
seen better days you know and a lot of
people are saying that buttholes the new
vagina to and those people are out of
their minds but homework at all you know
if there's a little more than you know
but my problem is you know I just write
stuff in my butt you know I'm not gay
but you know I like things in my butt no
just I'm doing this all right I feel
well look Brent I'm a serious man I
don't know much I'm not a doctor right
I'm not a you know a proctologist but I
know this if I go to the proctologist
every day and get that dude to put stuff
in my butt at some point he's gonna
probably come to the conclusion that I
like some type of homoeroticism
so if you like stuff in your butt dude
your butt is not a um I mean your butt
when you think about of your buddies you
know guys like caves guys like mystery
what's in there what's over there you
know you see guy I remember the Goonies
they went in that cave looking for
something and your butt hole is just a
special cave that's in the back of your
body and the worst thing I think about
your butt hole is you can't even see it
you can't even see it bro and I think if
we could see it more often we might not
be as into it but it has that mystery
you know your butt holes the Sherlock
Holmes of your body really it's that
mystery boy you know it's that
encyclopedia brown hole so if you like
stuff in your butt you might just be you
might want to be a drug mule
have you ever thought about that you
might not be a gay guy you might just be
wanting to run dope across the border
you know I'd love to you know when I was
young me and this boy got stuck in this
semi-truck and this man was putting
tootsie rolls in our mouths and I liked
that I guess but you know I didn't keep
doing it after that I'd have a tootsie
roll every now and then but I wouldn't
jacking my jaws up with him like that
man was in that semi truck and he got
his ass beat for being a PDF or alleged
but you got to think about yourself man
if you out there hiding and what kind of
stuff you didn't say what kind of stuff
you like in your buttocks if we talking
ice cubes or something like that or a
couple little marbles or something this
you might just be your own little boo
radley where you hiding things and
you're [ __ ] in your in your raw in
your bark you know you hiding things in
your own tree got a member Boo Radley
hid a bunch of stuff in a tree trunk you
might be a little bit of a poo Radley
you know what I'm saying you might be
that pool Radley daddy to kill oh ah to
kill a docking bird but are you docking
birds in your body
you know but you might be over there who
knows you hiding stuffing away in your
own body walls I don't know dude it
sounds like you might be gay to me but I
don't know who's gay anymore somebody
you know a buddy of mine he said he
hadn't eaten in a while and then next
thing you know some guys blowing him at
a party and that [ __ ] doesn't make any
sense dude I remember one night at a
party this hot chick told this guy she's
like while kiss you but you got to kiss
my friend first and her friend was gay
he was in the homeless ISM so next thing
you know the guys like alright I'll kiss
your friend who's a boy so she you know
the guy kisses the other guy and then
the girls like [ __ ] you I'm not kidding
you know she just was joking with him
she got him to kiss the guy dude when I
was in college or but one guy would pass
out and this other dude was always
blowing passed out dudes in saying it
was like a game or something and guess
what it wasn't even a game he was just
blowing dudes who was passed out it was
illegal it was an illegal 'ti so there's
all kind of stuff man you know but only
you know for yourself only you know for
yourself but what I know is that it's
been that time of year and that we're
still here together and whether you
hiding stuff in your butt you know
whether you are you know you want us to
have guests on the podcast or not
whether you are you know sending dick
pics to your teachers or your students
whether you pooped your pants you know
whether you almost bang your coworker
and didn't tell your girl about it
whatever we're all just people you know
and we have feelings and we just trying
to navigate our life okay and in the end
I think we all just want to be accepted
man you know and really we really just
also want to just be accepted by
ourselves
but I'm grateful to be here with you
guys
I'm grateful we have this weird place to
hang out every week for a little while
you know I never thought I would be
involved in something like this you know
I never thought I would I don't know
what I thought but I know that I
couldn't have I couldn't have this
experience today by myself and so I'm
grateful for the calls that came in I'm
grateful for our sponsors support those
if you can I'm grateful for tiny sand
who who sent in that Christmas jingle
you know and what else man what else the
years over you can wrap it up put a bow
on it go out different change it man put
it put a bow on the year don't just box
it up and get ready for it do something
special you know hook somebody put
something in somebody's butt or your own
but you know do something nice do
something different you know then we'll
be here I'll see you guys next week man
it's gonna be it'll be almost Christmas
when we talk again I think it'll be the
23rd so that's pretty cool pretty nice
man I'm grateful for you guys I'm gonna
go out on this Christmas time this is
called and and that's it man that's all
she wrote I love you guys man be good to
yourself you probably deserve it and I
hope to see you all soon and you know at
a Waffle House or you know in a
relationship or you know in a diversity
discussion I hope to have a new year
ahead of me rock and you know just try
and just be okay with myself and be okay
with others and even bigger and better
ways I love you
have a good day man
[Music]
[ __ ] I gotta get my inner depressants
they closed the CVS close I have to get
them [ __ ] move to a different CVS
just when you think you've made it
through life for the day
[Music]
you